this is
he likes to frame himself as the
billionaire of the people he is
apparently on the side of retail
investors he wants to spread awareness
about climate change and pollution and
he wants to change the world for the
better but chalmat is nothing more than
a master manipulator and a public
relations expert this is exactly how he
was able to go from being an unknown
Rich douchebag to briefly becoming even
more popular than former retail favorite
Kathy Wood Chalmette would consistently
go on to financial news outlets like
CNBC and the Bloomberg and spew
investment advice that he himself did
not believe in this would result in
millions of investors to consistently
follow his advice and to get burned
while chamet would always pull out at
the right time